foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
fisherman
good morning everyone please have a seat
so good morning distinguished colleagues
and good morning to you new master's
degree students doctoral students and
visiting students of The Graduate School
of Arts and Sciences
normally as you may have noticed in your
program president salave would open
matriculation ceremony by addressing you
all
but unfortunately he is sick and is
isolating at home
he was however able to record his marks
remarks so I'd like to draw your
attention to the screen where president
salave will kick off today's celebration
good morning everyone
I'm sorry that I can't be with you in
person today
although I feel fine I tested positive
for covid yesterday and in accordance
with the University's Health guidelines
I'm staying home
however I'm delighted to join you
through video
so I welcome you our newest class of
Scholars and celebrate the beginning of
your Graduate Studies at Yale
as you know I'm a professor of
psychology and my field is emotional
intelligence
but it is not take an expert to sense
the feelings out there today excitement
anticipation anxiety Joy worry Pride
I remember my own emotions when I was in
your position in 1981
I came to yell from Stanford
knowing that I wanted to study emotions
in general and the role emotions play
and the decisions people make about
their health in particular
when I arrived here I had a fairly clear
understanding of the work I wanted to do
in graduate school because I'm sure many
of you do as well
I had no idea however just how much yell
would shake my life both professionally
and personally
as a graduate student at Yale I was able
to collaborate with four Stellar
professors and with my fellow students
that work resulted in the exchange of
new ideas and the discovery of new
findings
I met people who would become lifelong
colleagues and more importantly friends
and I met my wife Marta but I'll tell
you that story later
for me graduate study at Yale was a rare
and precious opportunity
I approached Dale with an open mind and
I hope you will as well
I had the freedom to pursue ideas any
ideas that occurred to me a freedom that
to be honest I've seldom enjoyed since
I developed my research agenda design my
own experiments and explored my
intellectual passion in a way that was
both unfettered and at the same time
completely supported
you will embark on the work that you
will continue after graduation
as a graduate student in the psychology
department I wrote papers for my courses
that I could imagine revising for
publication
I was a dedicated teacher in the
sections that I led I collaborated on
Research in a lab
in short what I tried to do as a student
was what I was going to do when I
graduated
but you will also see as I do four
decades later with the benefit of
hindsight unexpected applications of
your Yale degree
I've relied on my varied insights gained
as a graduate student for example from
social psychology to data science and
Analysis
to help our community navigate an
unprecedented Public Health crisis
the open-mindedness of other Yale
graduate school alumni meanwhile led to
unforeseen possibilities
I think of one entering student who had
no intention of being a data scientist
while in graduate school in fact she had
no idea such a job existed
now executive director of data science
at the New York Times and Bauer relies
on the big data analysis pipelines she
wrote at Yale for problems she faces at
work
she's used her expertise to optimize
distribution processes and algorithmic
content recommendations
perhaps more important than the academic
and technical skills I learned and said
was what I'm sure every PhD student
develops the ability to approach large
difficult problems break them down into
pieces learn about them from scratch and
work them through to the end
I think of other graduate students who
have had their life trajectories
transformed by Yale for the benefit of
the world
for example Francis Collins The
Physician scientist who led the Human
Genome Project which has given us
information about the structure and
function of our genes entered Yale
thinking biology was messing
and had zero interest in it
a course that Yale changed his thinking
and subsequently the scientific world
now as you arrive at Yale at an
inflection point in history
what course could likewise change your
views or set you on A New Path in the
coming years
and what could it mean to the world
how will you engage in educational
experiences and then mobilize your
knowledge in unanticipated ways
graduate school for me as I suspect of
Anne and many others was not a dress
rehearsal for my career it was act one
of the rest of my life
I wish the same for you
you will not be alone as you tackle this
work
the faculty and staff of the graduate
school and throughout the university
will do everything possible to support
you and help you launch your career
after graduation
whether you choose to work in Academia
or Beyond it
the office of career strategy the poor
View Center for teaching and learning
Yale Health are some of the important
resources available to you please take
advantage of them and reach out when you
need help
as others have before you you will find
yell to be a place of excellence and
innovation
as you make your way here you will of
course come to know yell through your
own departments you will make friends
with fellow students in your disciplines
you will work with professors in your
own areas of scholarship
remember to to reach Beyond these
familiar circles and get to know the
wider Community during your time here
there are activities you can be involved
in for families and for international
students as well as public service
opportunities that can connect you to
the larger community be on campus
the whole campus is yours to experience
you have access to the Treasures of the
world here
the combination of new and renovated
spaces will help to nurture new ideas
and Partnerships and provide a platform
on which to build Next Generation
solutions to the most pressing Global
problems
this is especially Salient in Yale's
Innovation Corridor it includes the L
Center for engineering Innovation design
the Greenberg teaching Concourse of the
School of Engineering and applied
science and PSY City
the center for Innovative thinking at
you
that these hubs of creative activity you
can receive mentorship meet peers
outside of your area of study and
receive other resources to help launch
your ideas
we'll also have other opportunities to
innovate through the new
cross-disciplinary Yale Ventures program
this new initiative serves as the
University's home for entrepreneurship
and Innovation efforts offering training
and support for faculty students staff
and Community innovators to transform
their Research into products services
and social Ventures
of course elsewhere across campus a
world-class art museums are free and
open to the public six days a week the
Yale University Art Gallery and the Yale
Center for British art slated to reopen
this spring both magnificent collections
both buildings designed by Louis Khan
are architectural signatures
stop in stroll through one of the
Galleries and you will be inspired and
refreshed
you know Sterling Memorial Library is
among the world's largest libraries it
is a beautiful place to study or simply
enjoy a quiet moment
and just steps away the L Schwartzman
Center a hub for Arts culture and Lively
discussions
is buzzing with activity
in its first full year of activation the
Schwartzman centered welcomed Sir Paul
McCartney for thrilling discussion about
his life
and the lyrics of his songs
as its ethos suggests it is a space
where members of the Yale and local New
Haven communities can break bread and
break boundaries
our Peabody Museum of Natural History
meanwhile which is nearing the
completion of a transformative
renovation is home to an impressive
collection of dinosaur fossils including
the largest brontosaurus ever assembled
in the world
as one of the few universities in the
world with four schools of the Arts we
have a wealth of performances and
Exhibits from theater groups to symphony
orchestras and other musical groups
artists and student performances
there are amazing events almost every
night
many are free or offer steeply
discounted tickets for students
City of New Haven meanwhile Yale's home
has its own Treasures to offer networks
of natural charms and hiking trails both
within and near the city great
restaurants small shops bookstores and
the best pizza in North America maybe
the world
my wife Marta and I have lived in New
Haven since we came here as graduate
students and now reside on campus so you
may see us walking our dog Mandy down
hill house Avenue some mornings
on that note I encourage you to get
involved with student government
in 1983 I was president of the graduate
and professional student Senate
see where that leads
it was great because I met fellow
students from the school of medicine at
one end of campus to the Divinity School
at the other and many from the schools
in between
and most important for me I met Marta a
graduate student in public health who
was the vice president of the Senate
we've been married for 37 years
so I can't promise you will find the
love of your life through Student
Government at Yale but you never know
Yale is a wonderful and special place
I hope you will come to feel as much at
home here as I have for Wow 42 years
the late George Pearson who received his
PhD from Yale in 1933 and was a Yale
historian described Yale as at once a
tradition
a company of Scholars
a Society of Friends
I'm so pleased that you are joining this
tradition as Scholars and new friends
welcome to Yale
it is my pleasure now to introduce Dean
Lynn Cooley
now in her second term as the dean of
The Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
she has been a tireless advocate for
graduate students and a powerful Agent
of Change in graduate education at Yale
Dean Cooley is the cnh lawn professor of
genetics professor of Cell Biology and
of molecular cellular and developmental
biology and vice Provost for
postdoctoral affairs
and she was for many years the director
of Yale's combined program in the
biological and biomedical Sciences
she earned her ba from Connecticut
College and her PhD from the University
of Texas for a search carried out with
Sterling Professor Dieter Sol in yells
Department of molecular biophysics and
biochemistry
after postdoctoral training at the
Carnegie Institute of science she joined
the Yale faculty to study cellular
mechanisms underlying female and male
fertility
she's been recognized with a Pew scholar
award from the Pew charitable trusts and
she is a member of the Connecticut
Academy for science and engineering and
a fellow of the American Association for
the advancement of science
she served on the board of the genetic
Society of America for many years and as
its president in 2017.
Dean Cooley also has other interests
she's a frequent hiker in Connecticut's
many beautiful trails and a student of
modern dance
she is the devoted mother of two
daughters both Yale graduates
and so it gives me the greatest pleasure
to introduce you to your dean and one of
Yale's outstanding faculty members
Lynn Cooley
[Applause]
wow I'm so grateful that President
saliva took the time to do that given
that he's at home isolating let's give
him one more round of applause and wish
him well
I extend my heartfelt congratulations to
each one of you for embarking on this
transformative Journey you should be
proud of all the work that has brought
you here today
to The Graduate students
you were selected to be here because you
have proven abilities and we believe
unlimited promise
you are here because our faculty
recognized your intellectual curiosity
and creativity your academic drive and
rigor your passion for Discovery and
your potential for leadership
you are here because we believe you can
make valuable contributions to both Yale
and the world and because we know Yale
can help you on your path to
intellectual growth we're delighted that
you've chosen to join us
the graduate school stands at the very
heart of Yale's Mission as a university
we educate graduate students to seek
answers to Life's most most challenging
questions
we we will be working Across The
Graduate you will be working across the
graduate schools more than 70
departments and programs but whatever
your area of study may be cells or
Society
ecosystems or solar systems you all
share a common motivation you're driven
by the desire to learn more
by the thrill of discovering new truths
about our world and by the desire to
stretch your imagination and create new
knowledge
so I'll take the time I have today to
offer you three main pieces of advice as
you get started many of which Echo what
you've just heard from president salovey
the first is to fully engage with the
rich cultural and intellectual diversity
that surrounds you here at Yale
the second is to cultivate robust a
robust constellation of mentors from
among faculty staff and your peers
sitting right here with you
and the third is to be intentional
starting today with your professional
development so that when you leave Yale
you are fully prepared to pursue the
career you imagine for yourself
okay so let's start with the first let's
start with engagement
I encourage you to participate fully in
your community in ways that suit your
personal and academic goals best Yale is
fortunate to gather the best students
from across the globe which means you
come from all walks of life backgrounds
and identities
The Graduate School is committed to
creating an environment in which all of
you can Thrive and Excel
partly because we value diversity Equity
inclusion and belonging as core
principles of the University
but also because research shows that
diverse and inclusive groups comprise
better investigators and smarter
thinkers
during your orientation week you will
learn there are many student clubs
institutes and organizations to explore
you'll undoubtedly be able to find one
or more that matches your interest
if you're if you're interested in
student advocacy truly improving the
life of your fellow graduate students
you might get involved with the
government as Peter Salve did the
graduate student assembly
or The Graduate professional student
Senate which represents all students
across the University
Yale is a place that solves challenges
as a community Through trust
collaboration and honesty
you should engage with your classmates
and faculty share your unique
experiences and learn from theirs
I had my own eye-opening experience
while many of them as a graduate student
when I found myself in a lab where I was
one of a minority of Americans
surrounded by people from all over the
world
I learned learned things like a few
phrases in German and Japanese
but also I realized that our collection
of backgrounds and experiences meant we
could each contribute in our own ways to
the culture of the lab
my lab mates got a kick out of learning
some phrases in American Sign Language
for me
I still remember when one of the
postdocs I greatly admired realized his
experiment had totally crashed for the
day and instead of being forlorn like I
would have been he grinned at me from
across the lab and he signed free day at
me which then he took off early just
left
his reaction showed me that the drive to
take on to the drive sorry that the give
and take of different languages helped
create an atmosphere of trust in which
we could comfortably share research
ideas no matter how crazy they seemed
it also showed me it was okay to take
some free time when you hit a temporary
roadblock both of these were valuable
lessons to me as a young person in a new
environment
next mentorship
I want you I I want you to seek mentors
who will guide you support you and
inspire you to reach New Heights our
community is is known for its
collegiality and you will find a network
of people who genuinely want you to
succeed
don't hesitate to ask for help feedback
or guidance
your mentors and friends will be there
to assist you through any challenges you
encounter
the network you create
will give you the support you need to
survive and thrive in graduate school
you'll find that you'll you'll find the
graduate schools very different from
previous experiences you will find that
graduate in graduate school you are much
more responsible for your own education
than you have ever been before
your schedule may be less predictable
than it has been in the past
it won't necessarily be an easy Endeavor
and really it isn't meant to be there
will be challenges and obstacles ahead
but trust that you will move forward and
get past them
if you do start to think you're alone
remember that you are surrounded by
mentors and Advocates from all parts of
the campus faculty members staff and
your friends who will support you and
offer you advice when you need it look
to them for guidance and inspiration
you're about to embark on a marathon not
a Sprint pace yourself be kind to
yourself and others
ask for help ask for feedback ask
questions and Foster The Curiosity that
brought you here today
finally this may seem odd to say on your
first day of school
but I want you to start planning for
your career
remember the reason you're coming to
graduate school is to advance your
professional development
getting here brought you to the starting
line not the finish line
this is just a stage in what will be
along and perhaps sinuous career
we want you to leave you equipped not
only with academic Excellence but also
with a Clear Vision of your future
whether you already have a well-defined
goal or are still exploring your options
there are a range of resources available
to you while you figure out what's ahead
beyond your faculty and Department
the McDougall graduate student center
and office of career strategy are
invaluable resources to you as president
saliva said
offering guidance workshops and network
networking opportunities let's all work
together to turn your passions into
fulfilling careers
importantly you can also tap into our
incredible alumni Community by virtue
just by virtue of being here there are
over thirty thousand graduate school
alums out in the world with their own
unique stories around the globe
you can be in touch with many of them on
the cross campus platform
you should sign up for that right away
I encourage you to look at your own
departmental alumni to see the range of
career options that they have pursued
they can open your eyes to Opportunities
you may not have considered yet
don't shy away from building these
connections our alumni are excited to
support you and share their to share
their wisdom and experiences
so engage fully with the Yale community
build a network of mentors with various
perspectives and experiences and start
thinking about your future Beyond Yale
starting today
if you feel a bit unsure about what's to
come this is normal
in fact that feeling is the perfect
starting point for what you have come
here to do
your time in graduate school in fact is
very much about getting comfortable with
uncertainty and dwelling at the edge of
the unknown
one of our aims at The Graduate School
is to help you develop the ability to be
comfortable when faced with uncertainty
and mystery to become the scholars and
researchers you aspire to be who can
push forward the boundaries of what we
know and understand about the world
that search can be disconcerting and
difficult
but do not insist on certainty where
there is none nothing comes out of being
entirely comfortable all the time
some days things just will not go as
planned I have learned that lesson over
and over again
but I've also learned that the most
exciting days in my lab are when an
unexpected result leads to a new area of
study
it can be overwhelming to start this new
chapter of your life you're in a new
city meeting lots of new people and
figuring out to navigate the first steps
of the graduate school and this great
University
trust that you belong here
trust that bringing your whole self will
make everything better
trust that you will contribute
positively to the people around you
based on your experience and
perspectives
learn when to listen and when to speak
up to put yourself out there and start
conversations with people you don't know
over the next few days be intentional
about meeting new people and being open
to building relationships with them
remember these will be years that shape
you not only as Scholars but as
individuals make connections that will
last a lifetime
as graduate students you hold a special
place in the University landscape at the
intersection of all the research and
teaching happening across campus
you are not simply here to learn from
The Faculty but to learn with them
your fresh insights and persistent
curiosity are the catalysts to new ways
of thinking learning and creating we are
eager to witness and celebrate all that
you accomplish
and the world we will be waiting for you
to come out and share what you've
learned as soon as you are ready
the empathy you develop from being
immersed in a diverse Community will
better position you to offer Solutions
in ways that promote peace and dignity
for all concerned
you will become better communicators in
order to share your findings with
colleagues in your field but very
importantly allay public as well
Recent research recent history has shown
us that we all must devote energy toward
helping our leaders make decisions based
on fact and insight
earlier
I alluded to the fact that it's
important to take some free time in
graduate school especially when
confronted with challenges
there are a few ways to do this
some of which Peter saliva mentioned
already visiting our wonderful museums
exploring the city of New Haven or
joining student clubs and activities
to give you one sense of what some of
our students do to unplug and enjoy
their downtime I'm very pleased to
welcome the graduate school's own
acapella group The citations to perform
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
hello everybody
um we are the Yale citations uh Yale's
oldest you could say smartest best
looking
um and also the only uh graduate and
Professional School acapella group here
on Yale's campus
um we wanted to welcome you all on this
lovely morning and before we get started
um if singing is your thing please check
us out at the activity Fair coming up in
a few days and
um we will be holding auditions soon if
you would like to be one of the
citations
and also uh please check us out on
Facebook and Instagram the Yale
citations we'll be posting our audition
dates there and so without further Ado
we have two more songs for you all hope
you enjoy
I heard there was a secret chord that
David played in it please the Lord
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
we are
your faith was strong but you needed
[Music]
she's hiding to the kitchen chair she
broke your throne and she cut your hair
from your lips
[Music]
Hallelujah
baby I've been here before
I've seen this room
[Music]
before I knew
s
maybe there's a God above but all I've
ever learned from Love Is
[Music]
so Broken Hallelujah
Hallelujah
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I want you back yeah
boom baby give me one more time
[Music]
to let you go let you go baby
trying to live without your love is
treats
[Music]
since I see you in his eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
aren't they great let's have another
round of applause
today is the start of an exciting
Journey for you graduate students seize
the opportunities to grow to challenge
yourself and be sure to celebrate not
only your own successes but those of
your colleagues and Friends
Yale will have an impact on you but you
will also have an impact on this campus
and after you graduate on all sectors of
society we welcome you to this community
and we look forward to all that's in
store for you
it now gives me great pleasure to
welcome interim University chaplain
maytal saltier saltill to close out
today's ceremony with a benediction I
ask that you please rise and remain
standing until the platform committee
platform group recesses
from all corners of the world we've
gathered today a resplendent tapestry of
experience and wisdom ready to embrace a
new year together to build community and
engage in self-discovery
loving and holy spirit called on by many
names hold us gently and with care
May our time on this beautiful campus be
full of light and Truth transformation
and growth may we be open to awe and
surprise in Wonder of wisdom and
creation
remind us to be humble before the vast
knowledge of the universe
wisdom that is known not yet known and
unknowable
in the labs in the library carols the
late nights and the earlier mornings
remind us why we are here
ground us in our thirst for knowledge
and understanding
may we be a blessing may we move with a
heart towards Justice with the mind of
curiosity
with arms open with compassion with the
soul of Grace
we come here today as the fruition of
our ancestors wildest dreams may we live
into being good ancestors ourselves
we have inherited knowledge and
traditions may we shape them for a
better future for all
as we embark on this journey today may
we grow from strength to strength as we
say Amen
[Music]
thank you